foreign
JW Is With Us in Atlanta hijw how are
you
hey however y'all better than we deserve
sir how can we help
so I just started listening to you about
a month ago
um I never really known about you or
anything and I'm trying to figure out
how much of a stupid but Millennial I am
and
what baby step that I'm on which way I
should be focusing my gazelle intensity
uh I'm kind of lost at the moment and I
don't really know which way to go
well tell us about your situation right
now
um do you have how much debt do you have
uh the only debt that I have is my house
I've never owned a credit card and I've
never bought anything that I couldn't
pay for
well that sounds like a good start tell
us you may know a stupid butt Millennial
but you're not one of them okay so we've
already got that ahead all right but I
am curious why why do you think you're
making stupid bet decisions
well I mean some of what you guys say is
you know I've always just kind of done
it off of common sense or what I believe
those common sense
um I'm not the smartest guy in the world
so I'm trying to figure out well the
only difference is I sell it
I know that you guys normally promote
paying off all your debt before you
start putting money into your 401k or
not counting your house college funds
I'm not counting your house your debt
free except your house you said right
yes sir okay
that's right and I bought my house about
five years ago
um I owe about another five years and
it'll be paid off how old are you um
32. way to go dude you're killing it
yeah that's that's excellent so you
would be in baby steps four through six
right now which um it sounds like you're
investing right now how much are you
investing into retirement
I put 30 percent of my paycheck into my
IRA okay well we typically recommend 15
of your income and then baby step five
is paying for your kids college do you
have kids
yes William okay so we'd want you saving
in a 529 plan and then paying off your
house early which it sounds like you're
already really motivated in doing that
you just could you could just increase
that a bit take some of that 30 take 15
of that and throw that towards your
house but you're doing awesome okay you
know the only fine tune we might do is
turn down your retirement a little bit
down to 15. make sure you're doing
something for your kids if you're not
already and dump it all right so the
house might be done in like three years
oh that'd be great because it stresses
me out big time and then if it was done
in like three years instead of five
years because you're only putting 15
retirement instead of 30. you following
me if that happened then then you would
be at what we call baby step seven and
when you're there that's the last baby
step that's just build wealth and give
and you max out all retirement and you
pile up cash and you're outrageously
generous and you you know you've lived
like no one else and now you're ready to
live and give like no one else man I
will say JW you surprised me when you
said stupid about decisions I was ready
for something juicy
we were thinking you might be the color
of the week but no no you're just uh
you're just a just a smart guy I mean
you're way ahead of the curve yeah the
stuff we teach is common sense it's gods
and Grandma's ways of handling money it
lines up with what the scriptures teach
about money and what grandma are these
days great grandma because some grandmas
today ain't gain common sense but some
great grandma uh for sure it used to be
called common sense to live on less than
you make always have some money set
aside for an emergency always being you
know planning for the future called
retirement and kids college always be
avoiding debt if you can't pay for
something that means you don't need to
buy it uh keeps you out of debt it's a
um you know it's a different mentality
than uh 90 something percent of the
public has today and so uh Christina and
I got a big job right but the thing is
it's not complicated I think part of the
reason that he thought he wasn't winning
with money was because he's like this is
simple like I've been following these
principles and it's common sense since
it's simple I must be doing some
something wrong but
but it really is simple well it's not
easy but if there is this thing out
there and it's been there for the Whole
30 years I've been on the air I've
noticed it is that
people there's
and I I actually have fallen prey to it
in the past not in a long long time but
there's this thing that if it's not
complicated it must not be good when it
comes to money like if it's real simple
it must be wrong because I mean it has
to be complicated if it's money has to
be hard to understand if it's money if
it's not sophisticated you know it must
be wrong and the truth is the stuff we
teach and the stuff that works the best
is very easy to understand but hard to
do because you have to control the idiot
in your mirror
and the guy in my mirror is my problem
if I can get that guy to behave he can
be skinny and Rich but he's got issues
and you know that's a problem I like
donuts that's a problem it's a problem
and so um you know we all have this and
you know Rachel likes Amazon Prime click
click click click click the stuff keeps
showing up on her porch you know it's
like turn that thing off and so we all
do this stuff right and if we can
control our behaviors personal finance
is 80 Behavior that's why it feels like
it's
it should be harder it should be more
complicated but it but when you actually
face the demons it is hard because it's
the demons that are the problem it's not
the math the Math's easy right and uh
but yeah JW we always say around here
that uh common sense is so rare if you
get it it's like having a super